nowadays if somebody wants to get better
at the chess i can play it on an ipad i
can play on
how what was your strategy for getting
better back in the days what did you
read what did you have access to look
you know it's
um
i just got you know from moscow so my
cousin brought to me archives that my
mother kept
and those my
notebooks from the 70s 73 74 75 you know
handwritten notes and i showed it to my
kids
my daughter's turning 15. i mean she
couldn't believe that you know we had to
collect the data so this is now
it's all here we had to write the games
i even you know had a special set it's
by my coach
you gave me great present it's from east
germany i i could push i could put a
stamp with a diagram and then put chess
pieces on it so it's this is
again it was time consuming but it was a
great contribution to to to my work
ethics yeah because i had to do and and
it's it's again
my kids you know just that couldn't
believe this is this all this you know
notebooks
many you know many pounds of of of the
paper it's just this written so i think
it's just it's the
it's
life is always about trade-offs and of
course you know we had to spend so much
time but we could value information
treasury information you know i started
kasparov chess foundation in this
country 20 years ago and from 2005 we
have regular sessions with talented kids
when i said talented kids it's a top
level so and i can proudly say that us
juniors now does the best in the world
so that's we've made a contribution to
this success and
more and more i could see that the way
they play is so much influenced by
machines
and it's it's good that they can collect
all the data today the kid at h12 knows
more than bobby fischer learned in his
entire life again simply because he or
she could have swiped the finger and
just find all the data
but again how you deal with this data i
mean it's just it's the this can you
process it can you just you know
merge it with your intuition with your
human qualities because when we analyze
the games i i look at them and say okay
there is a move i said ah it's not a
good move so why it's not a good move
because machine said so
so i can also look at the screen can you
tell me why and many of them stared at
me
i'm being confused what do you mean why
because machines said so
so this is sometimes you know they lose
the this the ability the very human
ability to to to look deep down and
understand you know what it's all about
so it's you know it's just it's the many
ways of of of
describing the difference between humans
and machines making making decisions and
i always like to bring a quote from one
of the founding fathers of of ai joseph
weizenbaum who created eliza that's a
siri prototype in 1964 1965. in his book
in 1976 he talked about
difference between deciding and choosing
it's very subtle but he explained it
that you know that's the deciding is for
machines because it's computational
choosing is very human because at the
end of the day when you go way down with
machine
go to the very bottom yeah
i did it because i was told so
with human you go deep down
i did it because i want it
so it's very important to recognize that
you know no matter you know how much ai
is being introduced in our lives we will
remain indispensable that's what i
learned you know from the game of chess
so this is always an element of
human unique human qualities that cannot
be replaced by by machines i don't want
to sound callous yes every technology
you know brings problems and and you
know destroys industries but it also
creates opportunities
and it's very important for us to
understand even if we belong to the last
few decimal places
so what it's still very important for us
to actually find a way to channel this
immense power of of this brute force
very question for you a question for you
what you're saying because what you're
saying is uh we talked about this last
few days and it's a topic of discussion
nowadays that the thought about
computers eventually one day taking over
and doing the work of mankind absolutely
okay tell us unless you're brainwashed
by hollywood and the army of doomsayers
it's
yeah look you know it's very simple you
know this is the it's the you should
treat
computers ai whatever it is we can
discuss the the the uh the names it's
it's another human creation
it's not a magic wand
but it's not a terminator
it's not a harbinger of utopia or
dystopia it is a tool
you don't expect this to bring you to
heaven but it's not going to open the
gates of hell
and yeah it's easy to sell fear that's
why you have army of doomsayers telling
you oh wow
we're all going to die why machines made
us stronger machines made us faster
intelligent machines will make us
smarter
if we know how to use it
so there's so many new opportunities
just being open every day and by the way
we we're just now getting out of the
pandemic crisis
and it's in many of the debates we had
in the past you know oh it's
would you like to have driverless cars
or robots in the hospitals how many
lives could be saved if we had you know
these machines you know helping us
during this crisis and also this is
something that people just don't
recognize when they talk about computers
when you go back to chess
oh machines you know just you know if if
they don't reach 100 perfection they're
no good
nonsense there's no perfection in you in
the universe
all you should expect from computers to
do better
to make fewer mistakes
you mentioned my match with ibm computer
in 1997.
yeah
actually i won the first one in 1996
just for the sake of historical record
[Laughter]
um
and yeah faced other computers as well
but you know people say oh the 1997
match you know gary against the blue
that was the dawn of artificial
intelligence
yes
but i can tell you that deep blue was as
intelligent as your alarm clock
now a very expensive one about 10
million a piece
but still it was not intelligent at all
it didn't have to be intelligent
all it had to do is to make fewer
mistakes
it played decent chess
but it made fewer mistakes by the way if
you have a chess app on your mobile
it's as good or even better than the
blue
today
so and the the gap between
best chess player in the world today
magnus carlson and
a chess
engine that you can download on your
laptop
it's about the same as between usain
bolt and ferrari
so what
it's the it's this is again recognizing
that game of chess
game of go
uh game of thrones japanese chess video
games like starcraft or dota
texas holdem poker
those are all what i would call closed
systems
and the moment we we humans design the
framework machines will do a better job
simply because they make fewer mistakes
and that's you know that's the same goes
with the drivers cars
the moment something goes wrong with
driver's car you have a front page of a
newspaper now what about 40 000 people
being killed you know on the roads of of
this country every year by human
mistakes
so again the moment we understand that
you know we cannot push machines to
perfection and we could you know get you
know again this is like improving our
bottom line that's what we need
same you know just goes with ai and just
in business you know so many executives
and i speak a lot of course as as
patrick mentioned you know my last event
was in in january 2020 in france so but
but since that i had so many uh online
events
and i could even even on the screen i
could feel this anxiety fear you know so
how can we bring it in what about
explainability
so what are you there you know just to
explain you know how much it works or
you want to improve your bottom line
so it's it's it's in it
we should not expect what machines
cannot do but we should also be very
open understanding what it can bring to
us and how we can actually merge it so
how we can bring together us and
machines that's what i knew in 1997
that's what i you know why i introduced
a so-called advanced chess humans plus
machines
it's about finding how humans and
machines collaborate that's the way to
look into the future
fantastic with a question for you though
because you did say when you went
against deep blue it just makes fewer
mistakes than a human does right so if
you
were to get 50 phenoms
math phenoms they're great at math but
they've never played the game of chess
you get them you coach them for a year
a computer gets these 50 phenoms and we
do a project together the computer
teaches them
chess for 12 months okay so you got
computers ai you got gary kasparov with
writing on a sheet of paper 12 months
later these kids play against each other
who's going to be better at the game of
chess
will be one-sided which side our site
tell me why easily why because it's
about teaching because it's about it's
about you know uh transferring data this
is you know this is that's what i said
you know you have closed systems
but there's not a shred of evidence that
machines can transfer data from one
closed system to another closed system
even if you have you know the computer
you know dominating in starcraft pick up
a video game
the moment you shift it from one map to
another you have to start from the
scratch
that's again it's fantastic but but
again it's this is still a very human
human role to actually to to transfer
the data
now this is i always yeah i like you
know the quote that goes not from
science but from art from pablo picasso
who said computers are useless because
they can only give you answers
think about it
answers only
because it's it's as a great artist he
knew that you know to be creative you
know you have to ask questions questions
are a beginning
and that's where we belong
we have to ask questions oh machines
also can ask questions
yes but they do not know what questions
are relevant
it's very important that you understand
what matters most
and that's why and i remain optimistic
also the machine's getting more
sophisticated good good for me i'm 58 i
will never be as savvy as my kids you
know just you know
working with computers but this is a
moment where i believe my expertise my
wisdom my experience could actually be
an important factor to start you know um
uh very successful collaboration with
with these machines that will not
require you know a lot of technical uh
knowledge let me ask you a direct
pointed question and and i'm curious to
know how you react to this are you
saying that because you firmly believe
that are you saying that because you
have to believe that because
that's your signature meaning like if a
computer does better than gary kasparov
what's what's gary's you know so so are
you kind of defending your own
philosophy because
i'll give you an idea like you know how
people say stuff like you know uh time
magazine wrote an article talking about
the fact that millennials are lazier
generation than the current generation
right in rice's article you know
they don't work as hard they're all what
they want to do is they want to be on
instagram they want to do this and our
generation didn't do that and at the end
it says
if you say the next generation is lazy
it's just a sign that you're getting old
because the generation prior used to
also say that you were lazy so do you
think there's a part of us as we're
coming up
that we almost don't want to give in to
say ai is taking over it's going to do
the job better than us
do i look like someone who has any
doubts about what i'm saying
well that's the problem though that's
what i'm saying
the reason why i'm pushing your back on
this is to say do we sometimes have
blind spots because we're so confident
of what worked 20 years ago maybe not
today i was the first knowledge worker
on this planet who had his job
threatened by a machine
but i you know
and i again all i did after the 99 1997
match you know um
oh first i wanted to play the re-rematch
the third match and ibm made a good
business decision they knew that the
blue was good but you know the third
match probably would you know
give me a good chance of winning so and
since they know they had one of the
highest
performance for two weeks because the
ibm shares jumped 22
you know over the two weeks you know
since we when we played the match
and many of my friends said that my
biggest mistake was not to lose the
match but not to us the options
and um
um and i wanted to play the real rematch
and they says they turned me down and i
just i i was really upset you know so i
was looking forward just you know for
for just you know to prove that you know
i was still the best uh and um and then
the blue disappeared so i just actually
recently rediscovered that many of them
probably also saw it it's
it's it's doing sushi in jfk airport
terminal 5.
it's a great it's a great bar deep blue
so i love sushi never ate there
so but um
uh but speaking about this is it's it's
it's the machine says you know i i
wanted you know to
learn you know what's next and as i said
you know the next is
working together you cannot beat them
join them
again this is this is it's it's i took
time you know for me to analyze you know
this is the our performance versus their
performance but i found out that
machines will always have shortcomings
and the future of any successful
business is to finding the way how to
make contribution unique human
contribution to the very specific
machine to create a combination that
will be most effective for this task
sounds easy but it's tough and those who
can master the process will be on top
of the food chain so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]